[Music]
off the top I don't want to brag you
guys but I am wearing underwear that's
right thank you very much I like to keep
it all together keep it together like a
family portrait down there that's what
people always want to know you know
they're always talking about boxers or
briefs which you're better and I'd like
to put an end to that once and for all
just tell you there ain't no argument
its briefs briefs are way better am i
wearing briefs no what am i for I'm a
grown-ass man I don't want to look like
a hairy European going for a dip in the
Loch I like it a tad so you can see the
shrinkage
[Applause]
here's one zag briefs are way better and
we all know it sure other guys will make
funny huh be like older man panties they
look like panties yeah they look like
panties and they feel like panties
fantastic soft material no riding full
support it's like a cotton hand just
reach down your pants like I got you
baby it's like you all stayed hands like
are you wouldn't good homes there they
are
yeah I am man panty hands but I'm a
grown man you can't wear briefs you look
like you cook meth in a Winnebago
[Laughter]
Jess are you a boxer sucked too by
everybody knows boxers are no good but
guys they're always like boxes bro God
went box he's got let it breathe let it
breathe down there what do you got in
your pants underwear or a glass of Pinot
Noir let it breathe got a Lapwing
is it your underwear or a shoebox where
you're keeping a lizard let it bleed
poke some holes in there left let it
brew I'll keep doing it boxers are
garbage especially when you're wearing
shorts wearing boxers underneath shorts
is the same thing as not wearing
anything underneath your shorts boxers
are barely underwear they're not it's
just another pair of thinner shorts you
put on first so when you get that
perfect eclipse of boxers and short
lines up
when Grandpa Joe a few vodka lemonade's
in sloppily crosses his legs at the
picnic table you end up with front-row
tickets to old man balls the musical why
the musical cousin it made us laugh in
the writers room there's no makes no
sense
thanks for nothing boxers you know what
else I don't need those stupid print
designs on boxers those are popular
people love the prints last thing I need
is a guy wearing boxers that have
personality when does that work when I'm
two women ever been like how is Dan in
bed oh he was great
I could tell he had a sense of humor and
an erection so what do we do I'm wearing
boxer briefs right now boxer briefs but
I'm not proud of it down there with
their non-committal existential crisis
[Music]
they make you look absurd boxer briefs
they look like bike shorts you wear
boxer briefs you look like the guy in
Cirque de Soleil that you're not
supposed to be watching it's like I
throw the ball you deliver a utility
bicyclette
then there are the guys that just don't
wear underwear at all we have a word for
these guys psychos those you're psychos
holding their business up against denim
like it owes you money
[Applause]
those with the balls women think it's
sexy when they don't wear underwear
sometimes they'll be like I'm not
wearing any underwear but all I want to
say is be like are you okay are you okay
when you say that all I hear is I'm
chafing ready the exotic ointments wear
underwear women's underwear is sexy
men's underwear not sexy women's
underwear they got all the bows and
frills and it looks like you took your
panties to the dog groomer
guys don't have bows guys get a flap
just a crude opening the corrodes over
time so after a while just half in half
out all day I'm trying to get grocery
bags out of my back seat he's peeking
out down there like he's going to help
[Applause]
you got it forgot
you
[Applause]
[Music]